another very exciting edition of market
talks
i'm mark it takes wow messed up the name
my own show anyway i am dion robo and
i'm here in the office again i got the
big boss man charles farrell's office
he's let me use it again we had those
audio issues last week we wanted to make
sure and get that right for you all this
week so i appreciate you sticking with
me those should be all taken care of
today and we should be able to dive
straight into the big cpi inflation
report uh that came out this morning so
thank you very much for being with us i
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me uh and i
appreciate that so welcome in to market
takes look today's report uh was a a big
one because it really it's uh it's a
narrative shifter when it comes to the
pace of inflation uh the pace that i
think we can expect to see moving
forward throughout the year and the pace
that we were expecting to see from
august so we are going to dive into all
that we're going to talk about what we
saw in the report we're also going to
talk about how markets reacted if you're
looking at your screen you're seeing a
lot of red in the stock market you're
seeing bond yield spiking through the
roof commodity prices moving crypto
really across the board this report got
traders fingers moving so we're going to
talk about why that was we're also going
to talk about how the report stacked up
to expectations because that's a big
part of the market moves that we're
seeing right now we're going to talk
about some of the more important details
and the big takeaways from the report so
thank you so much for being with us here
on market takes let's get into it look
the august cpi number was 8.3 percent i
got it up right here on my laptop for
the year and it was up 0.1 for the month
those numbers uh you know without
context just kind of kind of sound like
whatever it's where we've been but
they were definitely higher than
expectations um and also we've got to
look at the core cpi report that report
that takes out volatile food and energy
prices that number was higher than
expected as well and this core number is
probably a lot of what's moving the
market this accelerating core number is
really a big part of federal reserve
expectations and what the market expects
the fed to do and today's report really
changed a lot of that
because the fed has talked about how
core prices are kind of a future looking
index they sort of signal what's on tap
for the future and those numbers came in
very high we saw on the core report an
increase of 0.6 which was about double
the expectation for the month and core
prices rose 6.3 percent for the year
again coming in above expectations i
want to drop one quick note from the
report that i thought was interesting
this is directly from the consumer price
index report that we got this morning
quote
increases in the shelter food and
medical care indexes were the largest of
many contributors to the broad-based
monthly
all items increase so what does that
tell you it tells you that the increases
that we saw were based on food
based on shelter and medical those are
three things that you know gas prices
have been moving the needle a lot on
inflation expectations but food and
shelter which you pay at the grocery
store which you're paying every time you
go out to eat that's going to start to
move the meal i think that's something
that we got to look out for in the
coming months i'll talk more about that
later
also falling gas prices had been a big
part of the overall expectation for
inflation to decline and for the
projections that folks have been talking
about we saw gas prices decreased by
10.6 percent the cpi gasoline index fell
by 10.6 almost 11
in august excuse me and still you got
this big increase or this above expected
increase 8.3 percent on the overall cpi
gas prices have fallen 90 days straight
and even that wasn't enough to get us to
expectations on the cpi report that's
notable and i think that's a lot of what
you're seeing in the market um
i talked a lot about the changing
expectations for consumers about
inflation the new york fed had a survey
that came out just yesterday it's august
survey of consumer expectations showing
year ahead expectations for inflation
had dropped down below six percent to
5.7 percent uh that was the lowest they
had been since november and the
three-year inflation expectations had
dropped to 2.8 percent much closer to
the fed's target they had been hovering
around that three percent level for
quite some time that had been concerning
the fed for a while federal reserve
chairman jerome powell said last
thursday quote it is very important that
inflation expectations remain anchored i
think the evidence today is that if you
look at longer term expectations by
households businesses and forecasters
and also markets you'll see that they
are pretty well anchored around two
percent after today that may be changing
um also food we got to talk about food
that's a big part of th this report was
all about food and all about shelter the
food component rose 0.8 percent in
august that has continued to rise even
as the headline cpi has been falling so
we're seeing food prices continuing to
rise even as the overall core or the
overall prices on the cpi have come down
remember we were at 9.1 percent back in
june 8.5 percent in july now 8.3 percent
here in august but we've seen ticking up
month over month of those food prices
what you're paying in the grocery store
is rising even as overall inflation is
decreasing
food is something that everybody buys
this is big for consumer sentiment we
get the consumer sentiment numbers the
final ones at the end of this month i
think those are going to be interesting
to watch we'll be here on market takes
talking about those so i hope you'll
join us then uh housing the other big
thing shelter housing rose by more than
expected and by the largest amount all
year in this report um look housing is a
lagging indicator on these reports it
takes the the folks the bureau of labor
statistics a few months you know it
takes them a little time to really get
housing prices factored into the report
and what we're seeing is that maybe the
increases that folks were paying for in
housing have been understated in
previous cpi reports and so we could see
that housing number continue to rise
throughout the year as the numbers start
to get put into the report that would
mean that inflation either stays stays
steady or starts to rise a little bit
higher that's not good news for folks
expecting these cpi reports or the cpi
numbers to continue to come down and get
lower
and also remember on housing housing and
shelter are the biggest components of
the cpi about 40 percent of the overall
report so as we see the price of housing
steadily increase as the numbers get fed
in you're seeing the cpi it's staying
right around higher levels and that
could hold up and cause the fed to do
more that's not good for markets that's
certainly not good for the stock market
and if you're a bond investor holding
those bonds that's not good for the
price of bonds either so look let's
check in with markets right now see
about the immediate reaction that we got
coming out of this number the number hit
at 8 30 a.m you saw an immediate spike
higher in those bond yields an immediate
turn down lower of stock prices let's uh
let's head to wsj.com right now and see
where we are on the markets you are
still seeing right now uh those stock
prices down and they've just been
tumbling lower throughout the day you
get the nasdaq down about 3.2 percent s
p down two and a half percent the dow
down about 2.2 percent as we look at the
bond yields i think that's really where
the story is right now if you're looking
at bonds
those yields are coming back down on the
longer dated bonds i'm looking at the
30-year and the 10-year and i'm seeing
the bonds spiked up after the cpi report
came out and they're kind of gradually
coming back down on those longer dated
bonds
the shorter dated bonds on the other
hand are those are coming down as well
you're seeing the two year and the one
year both come down
prices right now just a little bit lower
for the look for those uh shorter dated
bonds two year three year uh going all
the way up to the five years actually
still pretty high so
on the 10 year note which is the the
main one that everyone follows the
market benchmark you're seeing those
prices or those excuse me those yields
still higher uh but we are seeing a
significant move in the market right now
on the bond side that doesn't just hurt
bond investors remember the u.s
government when it's borrowing money and
it has to pay that money back that's
higher cost for the u.s government that
could mean a lot of things on the debt
side when it comes to you know borrowing
by the government it could mean that
some programs that would be financed
can't the republicans and democrats you
know kind of at loggerheads because it's
going to be more expensive to borrow
money that's certainly something to keep
in mind
as we look out i thought perhaps the
most interesting reaction to this number
was what we saw from fed fund futures
prices and that's basically folks
predicting what the fed's going to do
initially coming into this before the
cpi report you saw expectations largely
for a 75 basis point rate increase what
that means is about three times the
normal pace that we've seen from the fed
in modern history usually they raise
about 25 basis points to not you know do
too much not scare the market not move
rates by you know a a ridiculous amount
well they've gone three times that
amount twice expectations had been for
that coming in but today after the
report we are seeing expectations for
100 basis points we're now seeing a 20
percent expectation
according to cme group's fedwatch tool
of a 100 basis point increase that's
four times the normal rate and that is a
big move for the market so that's
definitely the the move and the the
market to watch i think today is what
we're seeing in expectations for the fed
because that moves everything as we're
seeing across the board right now
commodities are lower
oil has ticked up just a little bit it's
hanging out in positive territory but
you could see that change as we go
through today but that's just wti brent
crude is lower gold is down about one
point four percent silver way lower
copper down by about one percent uh corn
down by a lot and also as we look out at
currencies we're seeing the dollar
really turned back higher the euro was
down about one percent against the
dollar the dollar is higher against the
yen higher against the british pound uh
basically
excuse me basically across the board uh
as folks price in more work from the
federal reserve more rate hikes higher
rates in the u.s that draws money into
u.s treasuries and other us-based assets
that means people want to hold the
dollar makes it a stronger currency
that's good for americans if you're
traveling i got a trip coming up in
about a month very good for me i'm going
over to europe baby so i'm gonna spend
those euros that are about one to one
right now but if you're a business that
does uh that does business or that does
commerce basically if you're operating
multinationally in china and japan in
europe
means your profits take a big hit we did
a report and a video on that a few
months ago i invite you to check that
out
the biggest takeaway though right now is
more expectations for the fed to have
more to do and to raise rates by more
not just this year but into next year
that's the big takeaway from this report
again expectations were for this report
to show an eight percent increase year
over year and a decline of 0.1 percent
month over month
well above that the number came well
above that 8.3 percent um in terms of
the year over year and up 0.1 percent
instead of down 0.1 percent for the
month
a core cpi was expected to be six
percent came in at six point three
percent now that is we are on kind of
the wrong trajectory core cpi the fed
wants that to decline it wants core cpi
to go down because that's what they feel
like they have more control over core
cpi was five point nine percent uh last
month it was expected to be six percent
instead six point three percent so
you're seeing those higher rates of
inflation uh likely causing the fed to
do more at its meeting this month and
likely causing the fed to do more
throughout the year you're seeing those
prices
are booked into fed fund futures prices
and expectations across the market
let's check out the big takeaways i
think from this report as we're winding
down here getting close to the end of
the live stream
watch out for housing costs listen uh
that's been a lagging indicator and like
i said that could continue to push
inflation prices higher we've talked a
lot about gas prices we've talked a lot
about used cars autos all those things
because those were really skyrocketing
higher those have started to come down
but they're small pieces of the report
the the housing is about 40 percent of
the overall cpi number and it is just
continuing to rise higher if we see that
trend move forward in the months ahead
we could see cpi not only stay at these
levels but maybe start to rise again and
we could start to question that peak
inflation that kind of everyone had
agreed to back in june
that we had reached peak inflation 9.1
percent if housing keeps rising higher
housing is a big input and that could
move overall cpi higher definitely watch
that also good to watch food prices
that's another big part of this index
and food prices have continued to move
higher
um we were expecting that to kind of
economists were expecting that to move
lower that did not happen this month and
remember we thought inflation had peaked
back in march and then it picked back up
in june came down again we could see
another pick back up that would be a
real tragedy for the market especially
for stock investors especially for folks
who are investing those risky assets
crypto is just taking a bath right now
you're seeing ether and bitcoin down big
about three four five percent right now
this morning um our last takeaways as we
come to the end of this live stream
economists are really starting to worry
more that the fed is doing too much and
this report is likely going to give them
more ammunition more firepower to say
that we need to keep raising rates at a
fast pace get out ahead of this thing
and do more and there are more
economists who are starting to say well
we don't know that you really need to do
all that much maybe you're doing more
harm than good by raising rates at this
rate and by choking off the economy's
growth rate remember we've had
back-to-back quarters of negative gdp
growth already this year the third
quarter was looking good like we were
going to have positive growth but that
could be in question as the fed needs to
do more on the right side or as the fed
likely feels they need to do more on the
rate side
um today's news likely puts the wind at
their back to say we've got to do more
that fed press conference on uh on
september 21st that's going to be on
wednesday we are going to be right here
for market takes hopefully charles
ferrell lets us use the office again but
we might be in a new home but we'll be
right here on youtube delivering you the
market takes talking about what we heard
from the federal reserve and fed chair
jerome powell
also one quick thing on the housing note
be sure and check out the video we just
put out yesterday on renting versus
buying right now the rate mortgage rates
rising higher have made it the worst
time to buy in a very long time the
reaction today from cpi and from the
market suggests that mortgage rates are
going to take even higher and that could
hurt the housing market even more so
check out that report we did yesterday
that video that we did yesterday it's on
my youtube channel why now is a terrible
time to buy a house listen
thank you guys again for being with me i
am dion rabone reporter at the wall
street journal that is going to do it
for the live stream today thank you for
tuning in to market takes and be with us
on wednesday september 21st as we talk
through the fomc meeting the federal
reserves policy meeting fed chair jerome
powell's press conference afterwards
we're going to be breaking all that down
talking about the summary vex of
economic projections the market all that
i hope you be here don't be a
that's a square
and that's going to do it for us here on
market takes thanks again for being with
us diana bowen and i hope to see you
next week